courage women David Raymond
and Terry warden
as such a good example because I think
so many filmmakers out there think you
know what if I can just get these these
names actors in my movie and spend this
amount of money then then I will make
multiples of the budget and that simply
is not true i mean look at toronto this
year look at sundance this year how many
titles had huge names in them that still
do not have a distributor and if they
have a distributor the distributors
either aren't putting enough marketing
effort into into the films when they put
them in the theater you my guess is the
film that you're talking about they
proudly barely sent postcards and
posters to those 26 theater locations
and didn't spend any money on on the
advertising and therefore they they
yielded absolutely nothing and I see
that's I think people have just a really
a huge misconception about how easy it
is to make money in this business it's
very difficult I can think of a million
examples of films that are just not
seeing wider attention that are amazing
amazing films and the reason is is
because they simply are hard to market
or someone just hasn't put the proper
money or effort behind marketing those
films and I think that probably matters
more than almost anything how successful
film is financially is simply you know
is it marketable and and do people put
your money and effort behind it